gute nachrichten sie können ihr auto im
prinzip morgen in die schrottpresse
werfen denn ab sofort beginnt hier das
goldene zeitalter der deutschen bahn ja
ja der bund spendiert in den nächsten
zehn jahren 50 milliarden für ausbau und
modernisierung unseres deutschen zug
netzes das ist zwar immer noch viel zu
wenig aber doch ein schritt in die
richtige richtung und nächstes jahr wird
dann die mehrwertsteuer auf zugtickets
gesenkt wenn die billiger höchste zeit
findet dieser kunde presse wie im buch
preise den punkt hallo also deutsche
bahn und puff kamera ich vergleichen im
puff kommt wenigstens einer ja dieses
jahr wenn mal kurz zu den fakten kommen
dieses jahr kam fast ein viertel der
fernzüge zu spät die bahn schiebt einen
investitionsstau von 57 milliarden vor
sich her und es fehlt ohne ende personal
oder in den worten unseres
verkehrsministers bauern von ist mega
egal was der mann sagt ich muss immer
lachen es ist wirklich dabei ist er gar
nicht lustig am montag hat seine mega
bahn mit finanzchef dort schon wieder
einen vorstand gefeuert den fünften in
vier jahren mit der üblichen
millionenabfindung natürlich wegen der
geplanten preissenkung rechnet die bahn
mit 5 millionen neuen kunden wie soll
das denn funktionieren die fahnder jetzt
schon am limit teilweise doch und ist
kein witz mit technik aus der kaiserzeit
ja vom vom personalmangel mal ganz zu
schweigen
da müssen 100.000 stellen in den
nächsten jahren neu besetzt werden wenn
sie schon immer lokführer werden wollen
jetzt wäre die gelegenheit auch stefan
frauscher meyer fährt hier ohne
bezahlung eigentlich ist ihr arzt und
führt eine urologische praxis
[Applaus]
aber
wenn ich darüber nachdenke macht ja auch
sinn als urologe kennen sich natürlich
aus mit vergammelten alten tunnel so ein
lauf heute wahnsinn so vieles vieles
deutet darauf hin dass die deutsche bahn
sachen absichtlich verfallen lässt bis
nur noch ein neubau hilft denn für den
ist der bund zuständig und damit wir
steuerzahler entsprechende prämien
übrigens auch die bilanz des
güterverkehrs auf der schiene fahren
aktuell nur noch 19 prozent unserer
güter 72 prozent auf der straße ist doch
wahnsinn müsste da der staat nicht mal
eingreifen macht er ja von 2010 bis 2017
sind die mautgebühren für lastwagen um
20 prozent gesunken
die trassenpreise für die bahn dagegen
um 18 prozent gestiegen
cool klimaschutz mal anders nämlich gar
nicht die bahn tochter schenker betreibt
2700 güterzüge aber 34.600 laster hat ja
in vielen nachbarländern gibt es zum
teil eigenen trassen für den
güterverkehr bei uns in deutschland
müssen sich das mit den personenzügen
teilen und ständig warten teilweise
tagelang ich bin lokführer im
güterzugverkehr und ich fahre gleichen
zug der fünf tage verspätung hat
deswegen muss sie nach biblis aber sehen
wie kommen sie jetzt von hier weg ja
weil sie nicht ja kinder
er lebt er jetzt an den bahnhof als
penner wegen ihrer langsamkeit nennt man
die db cargo in frankreich auch dbs
cargo ging
egal heute ist wirklich schlimm so
der anfang der anfang vom elend der
deutschen bahn war in jedem fall die
privatisierung 1994 seitdem ist der
laden nämlich per gesetz gezwungen
gewinn zu machen und hat sich viel zu
lange kaputtgespart wir schalten wir
live an einen stillgelegten bahnhof in
sachsen an allzu valerie niehaus von der
presseabteilung der bahn
sie führt heute durch die feierstunde 25
jahre privatisierung ich denke wir hören
mal rein
ja meine damen und herren ich freue mich
dass es doch so viele pressevertreter zu
unserem kleinen event geschafft haben
nehme stark an mit dem auto wir wollen
mit dieser feierstunde mal anders jahr
94 erinnern ohne dass der heutige bahn
standard gar nicht denkbar wäre
in seiner ganzen erbärmlichkeit aktuelle
zahlen seit 1994 haben wir 6000 100
kilometer schiene in deutschland
stillgelegt das entspricht fast der
hälfte unseres autobahnnetzes kurze
zwischenfrage was genau feiern wieder
jetzt ein imagewechsel deutschland galt
immer als langweiliger streber europas
jetzt sind wir offiziell das nadelöhr
und der bremser des kontinents beispiel
die neue güterverkehrsstrecke von
italien nach skandinavien österreich und
italien bauen dafür einen gewaltigen
tunnel durch die alpen sind sogar im
zeitplan
der brenner basistunnel soll 2027 fertig
sein
die gleise in deutschland wird es
frühestens 2038 geben
ja ich sag das noch mal was so lustig
ist
die italiener sind im zeitplan wir
kriegen sich dazu jetzt ein offizielles
grußwort des italienischen
verkehrsminister de ski card sowie oper
lulu zu
er gratuliert uns herzlich zum jubiläum
und wünscht weiterhin viel erfolg
übrigens dieselbe peinlichkeit auf der
strecke genua rotterdam
auch da halten wir deutschen den
kompletten laden auf was sagt man dazu
in europa sind wir auch auf der schiene
einzigartig
das erzeugnis deutschmann sagt nicht
mehr das kinderdorf und faul sondern es
ist irgendwie einzigartig
geht's noch fragen ja nochmal genau
dieselbe was feiern wir da habe ich doch
erklärt ein neues image von deutschem
boden darf nie wieder einzug ausgehen
so und nun spielt um unsere rolle als
bremsklotz europas zu feiern das brutal
zusammen gesparte bahn orchester die
europahymne
bitte sehen wir betreten volltrunken
himmlische dahin hab ich zwar nie aus
china in kauf
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show you tube kanal als begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort